there's a long line of artists in my
family I started drawing when I was a
little kid and I could pick up a you
know pencil and a brush and started
doodling as I got older I just kept kept
with it when I meet random people and
they say oh you know what do you do for
a living I paint contact lenses for four
family television and they go somebody
does that I'm like well yeah somebody
has to it was a complete fluke I was
working with a makeup artist that would
occasionally go to set and put contact
lenses in which I call lens technician I
tried it out the first time I was hooked
it's a very small canvas painting
painting canvas so I have to use very
fine fine brushes a few hairs basically
it's a process it takes a few hours
sometimes a few days to complete
depending on what the design is
the corneal size cover your pupil and
your iris the ones that cover the white
of the eye those are called sclera
contact lenses the reasons why would we
use sclera contact lenses is like for
instance the branch or the whole eye is
just you know yellow another reason is
flood shot or a hemorrhage when
someone's been hit in the face I worked
on a few giant depth films
alice-in-wonderland pirates the
Caribbean and I've worked with Angelina
Jolie for a couple of her shows
including Maleficent her makeup artist
Tony Jay showed me a rock and it had all
of these flecks of different colors in
their blues and greens and pinks so
basically I try to incorporate all of
those colors into that lens there is
competition there's only a few of us a
handful less than ten I think there's so
many things I love about this job I get
to paint I'm an artist I get to paint
for a living
to see them finish their makeup and
putting the contact lenses everything
just comes together is the finishing
touch you know it's the cherry on top